vous vouliez devenir avocate oui c'est
ça j'ai fait un tout droit et en fait ça
avec l aval du lieu
[Applaudissements]
c'est la pire le 2 mai 2011
alors donc tu as fait un nom à l'endroit
parce qu'à la base moi c'était mon rêve
je n'ai vraiment être avocate et j'ai
déchanté très très très vite donc du
coup je me suis directement lancer dans
la comédie et ça fait plaisir quand même
à vos parents de voir que oui ils vont
tout tout de suite
enfin ils ont toutes les fautes à fond
avec moi j'ai vraiment fait tout ça pour
le droit il était super content après il
ya eu un petit doute quand même quand
j'ai dit j'arrête le droit j'arrête la
fac et je me lance pour faire comique au
début ça fait un peu peur mais j'ai la
chance d'avoir une femme qui était à
fond avec moi et au contraire ils m'ont
poussé ce qu'ils me trouvent les scènes
ouvertes et tous donc vous êtes inscrits
aux cours jour on vous avait passé cinq
années vous avez joué du tiers du racine
bien sûr j'ai passé un an qu'on fera
allait passer sa conférence 50
non mais vous vous êtes là vous voulez
là allez faire un tour
allez allez va aller voir si je suis pas
sûr c'est à vous merci et rapidement
vous avez laissé tomber droit donc comme
vous dites
et il paraît que c'est grâce à votre
sueur qui vous a réservé une salle de
spectacle par surprise comme cadeau de
noël c'est ça si on fait a dit gymnase
c'est ouf josé pas me lancer je savais
pas comment il fallait faire et du coup
j'ai une soeur qui est mon aîné de cinq
ans et du coup elle s'est renseignée
elle a alloué pour moi le théâtre du
gymnase une petite salle de 90 places
elle m'a dit tu écris un spectacle on
invite mes amis tes amis et sites au
monde rigole qui me promet de son adn
est totalement différent du coup et tu
me promets de te lancer et elle essaye
de tous les quotidiens restent pas
devoir rentrer c'est normal c'est super
intéressant ils peuvent rentrer quand
même bien par contre qu'est ce que vous
voulez j'aimerais j'aimerais bien que
les revenus
[Rires]
parfois dans la plus nouvelle de majora
castaldi apparemment il est allé sur
colis les îles et des rails alors en
2001 note égale jamel comedy club et
vous commencez à jouer régulièrement à
paris et c'est en 2009 que tout
s'accélère ou participer pour la
première fois au marrakech du rire et
déjà vous fait un carton je me rappelle
c'est ça ce que j'ai fait et je me suis
aimerait tellement être une meuf
instagram c'est mon rêve toile et
maintenant je parle pas ça ils font des
photos en tenue de sport comme ça mais
sans le double menton mais tu as atteint
et après lemaitre hashtag elle si à
chaque figure atakpamé
[Applaudissements]